good day everyone and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia please allow me to welcome you
to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general
medical sciences it is my honor and
privilege today to welcome our speaker
dr
vince calhoun from georgia state
university with additional appointments
at georgia tech
and emory university dr calhoun got his
uh
bs in electrical engineering from the
university of kansas in 1991
followed by master's a masters of
engineering
biomedical engineering from johns
hopkins university i'm a master of
science and information systems
from johns hopkins university and then a
phd in electrical engineering from the
university of maryland
in may of 2002. he's conducted primary
research at yale university and spent
many years at the mind institute at the
university of new mexico
in 2019 he joined the faculty at georgia
state university
where he is the founding director of the
tri institutional center for
translational research and neuroimaging
and data science
this is a partnership involving georgia
state georgia tech and emory
universities
and which focuses on improving our
understanding of the human brain using
advanced analytic
approaches with an emphasis on
translational research such as the
development of predictive biomarkers for
mental and neurological disorders
dr calhoun has built a career on
developing techniques for making sense
of complex
brain imaging data the use of big data
approaches in neuroinformatics tools to
capture manage and analyze and share
data is a major emphasis
because each imaging modality has its
limitations the integration of these
data
is a vital need to understand the
healthy brain especially
also the disorders of the brain dr
calhoun creates algorithms which seek to
map the dynamic networks of the brain
structure
um and the involvement of genetics and
how these are affected
um while being stimulated by various
tasks or individuals with mental
illnesses
dr calhoun is an author on more than 650
peer-reviewed journal articles
over 750 technical reports abstracts and
conference proceedings
he served in many leadership roles in
the field of neuroimaging and data
science
he is a fellow of the um uh institute of
electrical
uh and electronic engineers a past chair
of the organization for human brain
mapping
amongst other accolades uh he's been
awarded over a million dollars
or sorry a hundred million dollars and
counting in federal research grants
to study the topics of of neuroimaging
related research
and his talk today is entitled
brain-based biomarkers a focus on the
heterogeneous
enhancing sensitivity to brain disorders
and change as always
we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording by youtube and if you are
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us
also our specially selected 2020
uh 2020 2021 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr calhoun by the chat feature in
their zoom sessions i'll synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf
at the end of the lecture and with that
welcome vince we are so excited to hear
about your talk today thanks jack it's a
pleasure to be here
um what i am going to be doing today is
talking about some of our work in trying
to move towards brain-based biomarkers
um but in particular with a a focus on
heterogeneity um you know and how do we
use that
in in order to enhance our sensitivity
um so i'll go through kind of some some
uh preliminary work
um and motivation and then i'll talk
about sort of a number of different
ways in which we've tried to tackle this
issue
um so i think um
when we're trying to develop you know
neuroimaging
biomarkers of brain disorders or health
um there's often this sort of back and
forth between a focus on sort of
individual changes and you know
canonical
changes like do we can we find something
that's sort of representative right of a
group or a
a set of of individuals and that's kind
of a
circle or a cycle and and if you look at
the field you see studies go back and
forth between
group differences individual prediction
individualized change
than trying to develop more general
generalizable
information so um i think this is really
kind of an important
cycle and that's a little bit what i'll
be touching on today
um there have been sort of a huge
increase in
recent years in studies focused on
trying to get at
sort of prediction right accuracy
classification etc
this is a review from a number of years
ago where we started to look at this and
you can see
you know sort of some of the accuracies
here across various
uh brain disorders uh there's a pretty
big spread
um there's also you know a trend of
higher accuracies with smaller end data
sets which which probably gets at some
bias
but there's also you know quite a bit of
evidence that
brain imaging can be useful and accurate
at predicting various aspects
um that may potentially be important for
uh clinical translation
um and we can predict you know not only
do
doing sort of binary classification of
you know group a versus group b but you
can also look at sort of regression or
predicting continuous continuous
measures like symptoms or cognitive
scores
etc and this is sort of a more recent
review where we kind of looked at this
and a couple of the take homes we found
here
when you incorporate multiple imaging
modalities you tend to get higher
accuracies uh than unimodal you can kind
of see the distribution here
and the other is that you know if you're
looking at a patient group the
the accuracy within the patient group
tends to be higher
than the control group and this is
probably because the emphasis in a lot
of the studies were focused on sort of
symptomatic um aspects more relevant for
for patients another
another area that um that i've been uh
interested in and i think it's going to
be really helpful as we try to
again move towards biomarkers
are these sort of large-scale
competitions and so that this is just an
example of one we did
just recently um which had a pretty good
turnout we had about 14 000 entries and
this this was the
sort of the first ever uk biobank based
um
brain imaging competition and it used
functional mri and structural mri
almost 12 000 brains um
and it was sort of a collaboration
between trends
the human brain mapping organization for
human brain mapping ieee and the uk bio
bank
and one of the reasons these are useful
is because you
again it's pretty easy for bias to creep
in when you're trying to do
classification and prediction even if we
really try
hard to cross validate keep things
completely separate
competitions are a nice way to sort of
try to benchmark
and evaluate algorithms from groups that
are completely outside of
uh of your own um
another area that i think is is kind of
an important area is sort of
um there's another cycle that that um
that i think is important here which is
sort of looking back and forth between
data driven approaches and model based
uh approaches um and i think there's
there's a
um a big um area of
uh need for more hybrid models that sort
of blend those two
and what i mean by that is essentially
using priors right
so here's an example where you know
we've done quite a bit of ica of course
but one of the things about ica is that
you know it's completely data driven so
if you run it on a different set of
subjects you might find slightly
different components it might be a
little bit hard to match
you know etc you can kind of
blend the best of both worlds if you use
something called spatially constrained
ica
and so the way that we approach that is
we
we took two fairly large data sets and
we did
sort of independent ica analyses on
wrestling fmri data
identified the components that
replicated uh between the two
uh and then we used those to derive a
set of sort of component maps
that we can use as priors in a spatially
constrained ica
and so there's a number of benefits here
one of which is
you can directly compare uh across data
sets very easily because the components
are essentially
linked and you can see again here
how similar these two connectivity
matrices look these are basically the
cross correlation between
the time courses associated with ica
spatial maps uh in two separate data
sets and they're
correlated above 0.95 um actually i
think this is like 0.98 or something and
then
importantly if we look at group
differences between schizophrenia and
and healthy controls here you can see
that these patterns
also look highly similar they're a bit
noisy they're small effects but these
are the ones we're really interested in
and if you threshold these maps you're
correlating at about 0.95
the other benefit here is that we can
estimate this in individual subjects
right so we're just taking the priors
we're estimating a result from one
subject so we don't need a group
um and a third benefit is it it
basically provides
uh sort of adaptive spatial maps and
connectivity
information that we can then compare and
cross-validate quite easily
and these kinds of network-based
approaches where we're looking at sort
of
maps as opposed to specific regions
tend to outperform you know region of
interest based approaches
here's one example where we applied this
to
essentially predict a response to
uh antidepressant or mood stabilizer in
young adults who came into a clinic a
mood disorders clinic
um and a number of whom who were unable
to be diagnosed because they were in the
euphymic
state and some of them who were
diagnosed incorrectly put on the wrong
medication
and so working with beth osich and
london ontario
basically scanned at baseline these
individuals
and then followed them up very carefully
over a course of several years
and eventually determined which
medication
they were most responsive to that worked
best for them
and we use the baseline image to predict
uh that follow-up
uh medication um and we were able to
do this with an accuracy of about 95
so that was quite promising and it's
it's something it could potentially be
useful
clinically especially given that
some of these folks when they're put on
the wrong medication can get
can get ill and
it also hints at you know we can we can
identify networks that are most
predictive
uh in this case uh and you can see that
the ones that
that came out shown here in color um
and that can sort of hint a little bit
at mechanism and potential
you know targets for future treatments
as well
so again it's just sort of an initial
and the other thing that i like about
this study is
it completely ignores the dsm diagnosis
it's it's really just looking at
medication class response
um another example is uh here shown here
where we're looking at
uh ect response and so this is a
treatment for
major depressive disorder um and
some folks will respond uh
uh and and and persist in their their
response to the treatment others will
will have an initial response then taper
off and if we look at predicting the
the accuracy post ect with a baseline
um resting fmri scan we can we find
about a 78 or 77 accuracy
in in predicting uh the change in the
depression rating scale
that was measured okay so
so that's sort of you know where we want
to head and i think there's a lot of
potential
applications there that can be looked at
but there's an unsolved challenge here
uh which i i didn't touch on yet uh in
those previous results
which is we need to know what we're
predicting uh in order to
train a model to do the prediction right
um and so
if we don't know that then it's called
unsupervised right or unsupervised
clustering
and so you know here is an example where
you know i've
clustered a data into four clusters and
you can always find
you know groups of data that fall into
clusters naturally
but if you take those if you take that
data and then you map
say in this case we had four um
mental disorders represented uh each dot
here as a subject
and we map the disorders on to the the
same
uh representation you can see it doesn't
look particularly useful in terms of
telling us
anything about the the diagnosis
and that's because you know the brain
doesn't exist just to tell you about
your mental disorder right it's there's
a lot of things
that the brain is doing uh and uh the
data
is is you know is is not necessarily
going to be reflective of what you care
about
and so this is one of the reasons it's
such a big challenge
so one way we've tried to get at this is
using approaches based on something
called
by clustering um and sort of subsequent
extensions that we've developed
and this approach was initially
developed to look at
genetics genetic data and here is an
example where you have conditions
there are h conditions here and these
are the
genes and their responses whether it was
sort of on or off
uh positive or negative um you know or
non-responsive
and what by clustering is doing is to
jointly group
conditions and genes together so here
you can see
you know uh data like this gets grouped
into
two different bi clusters where genes
one four and nine show consistent on off
responses to the different
um uh conditions there genes one four 6
7 and 9
show consistently positive responses to
conditions b e and f
and so you can think of this as you know
so you can kind of get at here
uh looking at subgroups of individuals
right
or potentially subgroups of responses or
brain patterns
and so that's what led us to sort of our
initial study looking at
structural mri and so what we're doing
in this case is we first um
took some t1 structural mri data
segmented it and then applied ica
to those maps something called source
based morphometry so it's like a
multivariate extension of
of vbm or voxel-based morphometry we're
essentially
uh extracting uh maximally spatially
independent
patterns of gray matter that co-vary in
a similar way
among subjects and so
what we decided to do was to take these
sub these loading parameters which tell
you
the degree to which a given subject
expresses a given source map
uh and do by clustering on that and so
we um with the by clustering algorithm
we're essentially taking two components
here
uh and we're jointly clustering subjects
and components
um together um and this was
in the case of looking at symptoms uh in
uh individuals with schizophrenia um
and healthy uh a healthy group as well
um and so when we're looking at symptom
subtypes we essentially found
three sets of uh subjects
or subtypes one of which was
uh heavily weighted on positive symptoms
and loaded on one component here
another one of which was heavily loaded
on negative
symptoms and loaded on a different
component and a third one which was sort
of jointly loaded
on both components and was more
generalized in terms of
associated with generalized symptoms
um and so you can kind of see where this
is going this is really trying to get at
can we um you know look at the
variability in our data and see where we
have consistent
sort of apple to apple comparisons and
so another example where this
which sort of highlights the benefit of
this type of an approach
um is if we extend this to sort of n-way
clustering so instead of just two we
have multiple
same kind of scenario where we have
structural mri and we have
loading parameters here um but we buy
cluster
on all the combinations of the
components um
and we also include symptoms right and
so we have
positive negative and generalized
symptom
categories that are also included as um
as data types there and so what we
found was pretty interesting i thought
so first we have
uh by clusters here that only include
components and you can see
component numbers listed here and i know
that doesn't mean a lot
the specific numbers are shown here um
after the semicolon tells you how many
of the subjects were grouped in to that
by cluster
and interestingly you can see here where
the certain black circles are that we
get
um a significant relationship with
various
symptom categories um which does not
um uh is not reflective if we don't do
the by clustering we don't find
uh a strong relationship with symptoms
um
and the reason for that is because what
we're doing is we're sort of focusing on
homogeneous subsets of individuals um
again more of an apples to apples
comparison and within that the
variability is lower and the
relationship to symptoms emerges
um and likewise we find certain patterns
of symptoms
that are linked to certain components
right so here we have a
component 14 is co-varying these 60
subjects
covari between component 14 positive and
generalized symptoms okay so this is a
lot of data
there's a lot to take in here but i
think it's a really useful way to start
to tease apart
some of these data sets while getting at
heterogeneity
in individuals and of course
we kind of keep going here so we said
well can we apply this to fmri data
and look at dynamics and uh so
uh we we did that where essentially
we're jointly clustering on
windows which is basically sliding
windowed
uh cross correlation patterns you can
see shown here
right uh sets of subjects
and pairs meaning individual cells
within these connectivity matrices
okay so here here we've got in you know
what you're doing in dynamic
connectivity is you're essentially
computing
the the functional connectivity in sort
of a sliding window
fashion and then you can cluster those
into
states you know patterns transient
patterns of connectivity that
individuals move
close to or farther away from over time
and so with the triclustering approach
um
we basically applied it to a large data
set of
about 300 plus
individuals with schizophrenia and
healthy controls
and were jointly clustering as i
mentioned
windows and subjects
and pairs and so what we found was again
an analysis that showed a much increased
sensitivity
uh to patients versus control
differences and and here you can see
if a cell is white so these are five
different states
that that occur at different times in
different individuals
these are this is the control the
patient and the difference
and all of the ones that are shown here
are significant
the ones that are white are excluded
from
the tricluster because they they weren't
homogeneously associated with that set
of
again here you can see 3 500 windows
81 subjects and 619 pairs
in this matrix that came out and we
found three of these were
individually linked to either
generalized negative or
positive symptoms and there were
actually quite a lot of interesting
results that are fleshed out more in
this paper that i've listed here below
okay
another source of variability that we've
been trying to get at
um is spatial and temporal variability
okay so the dynamic
functional network connectivity tries to
get at that to a degree
um but um you know the majority of
temporal dynamic studies have
have focused on just coupling between
fixed regions right so the
the correlation between these two
changes over time right it goes
up or it goes down but you can also
imagine spatial dynamics where maybe
maybe the nodes that you're looking at
shrink or maybe they grow or maybe they
shift a little bit
and then you can have joint spatial
temporal dynamics right so so i think
these these latter two are only just
beginning to be studied
in in the field there's been quite a few
studies of temporal dynamic
um uh in the field and and what we're
finding is that there's actually a lot
of
evidence that spatial of spatial
variability in these functional
patterns that we're seeing um this is
just sort of one initial way to kind of
look at that
with within each it's sort of a
hierarchical analysis so within
each sort of domain we can look at sort
of sub-clusters and how they couple
differently over time
create little transient movies within uh
within the domain so this this is for
example subcortical um
network domain and you can see how it
changes over time
and importantly if we look at sort of if
we look at a patient and control group
we see the coupling varies quite
substantially
between the two over time in in just the
spatial
aspect of the dynamics okay
and then a third category where we're
kind of getting at that as
well is well instead of just
focusing on a pattern of connectivity
that you know or
you know fixed states right that occur
maybe we have five states
they they occur at random times in
different individuals if it's resting
data
um but maybe those states actually have
some
some behavior that that that you know
occurs smoothly over time can we look
for sort of motifs or
transient changes in these larger state
patterns
um and so those we we call statelets
essentially sort of short little
transient motifs around
those states um and interestingly well
why did we do this well
when we started to look at this in you
know in a patient data set
we find very striking uh differences
between the two for example the
the healthy individuals are showing
much more um evidence of
you know longer recurrence right over
time before it kind of tapers off
and disappears almost like a ripple in
the water whereas the
the patients show more more sort of an
up and then almost
off fairly soon um you can see here
the time decay it's almost night and day
right we see
a fairly uh dense uh
link here when we look at time decay um
in
in the healthy individuals whereas
there's almost very little to nothing in
the schizophrenia patients
classification you know using time delay
is is
significantly higher than it is uh when
we're using
uh something like connectivity patterns
for example
so again this is just another example
where again trying to
dig into the data and and represent it
in a way that
that captures some of that variability
okay the the other sort of elephant in
the room is
always the diagnostic labels right so
for example if we're talking about
schizophrenia and schizoaffective
disorder um you know some of which are
individuals that experience manic
episodes others
more depressive those are all based on
self-reported symptoms and interviews
and and they're not biologically based
right
um they're useful clinically uh
but they're not biologically based so
they're not really getting at the core
of the disorder and so we know that
they're they're not
perfect right and so how do we deal with
that when we're trying to do a
classification study
here's an example where we just applied
a technique uh trying to look at
labels so in this case a label would be
a diagnosis
and we treat those labels as noisy right
so we allow them to
have some error right and you can
you can do this one way to sort of get
at well
is there error or not is if you apply
multiple classifiers
across you know across
the data and then you look at whether
the classifiers
agree or whether they disagree
consistently um and so that gives you
some
evidence of of whether they're noisy or
difficult or challenging
and should we re-label them potentially
and you can do this
uh we applied this to this approach to
some numeric data so this is the mnist
data and we took numbers that sort of
look fairly similar
and kind of could be confused with one
another so eight
threes fives you know here's a one
and you can see if we apply this
approach to basically
identify the the noisy labels and
relabel them
we improve uh the accuracy up to a
certain point
uh so it doesn't overestimate it
actually is improving the result in this
sort of well-defined case
and then we then we decided to apply
this to um
structural imaging data from uh this
um psychosis spectrum study
um and we are looking at it with sort of
two different categories this this is um
uh the um
the b snip uh study which which is
looking at
um uh trying to define something called
a biotype
um which is using a set of data to that
includes
biological data and trying to identify
sort of a clinical
type right and sort of ignoring the
diagnosis right so they
they have in that study uh identified uh
you know three sort of biotypes in this
case they're labeled one two and three
and we also have the the dsm categories
in this case bipolar schizoaffective
with psychosis
um etc and when we look at sort of
original versus
cleanse which is sort of denoised uh you
can see that the accuracy
you know increases right significantly
it goes up uh quite a bit
uh for these pairwise comparisons as
well as for the
the hallway comparison um
and but importantly you know we we've
got again
in this case two different
categorization
approaches one is dsm one is biotype and
if we apply
either one of those we see an
improvement
and we see sort of meaningful separation
and when we look at the voxel-wise
comparisons of the relabeled data
the regions that come out as showing uh
differences in gray matter
are sort of meaningful right and they
reflect some of what we see
in previous work um and and much more
with much more sensitivity than what we
typically find
but they're not the same right so this
kind of then gets that well what what
else could we do here
you know it's it's almost like using a
prior right you're taking your
dsm labels as a prior but it's not fixed
and it can shift
right if you take biotype you might get
a slightly different answer so
so you know we can think about well
maybe we should use multiple categories
use all the information
we have at hand or you know
we could you could you can get you know
get there's a lot of things this sort of
could
could lead to but it's really trying to
say well let's let's
let's ex let's just expect that the dsm
categories are
error-prone and not biological and and
allow the algorithm to
try to update those okay
and then the last topic i wanted to
touch on was you know
sort of heterogeneity in the context of
of deep learning
um so deep learning has um uh has had
sort of quite a lot and see if i can
turn off my
menu here hide video panel try that
whoops no
i had floating meeting controls okay
i'll never i'm never gonna be able to
get those controls back but oh well
um so you know here was a sort of a so
we've been looking at deep learning for
you know a number of years now um and
it's clearly beneficial clearly has some
areas where
it can it can give you information that
you don't get from
standard approaches um here is one
more recent study where we looked at
some large end data we used the uk
biobank data
and we looked at um comparing deep
learning with what we're calling
standard machine learning
and so that would be things like linear
discriminant analysis logistic
regression support vector machine
um and um you know we we divided
the categories into groups of age so
there were essentially five different
age groups as well as females versus
males
and you could see in all cases these top
two black and blue
uh uh bars on this graph are the two
deep learning approaches
and these are all the standard machine
learning approaches and you can see even
up to ten thousand subjects and even
down to
you know only a hundred um where
you know deep learning is is
outperforming in terms of just the
accuracy
right but of course we don't want to
treat this
as a black box and one of the strengths
even though it's talked about often as a
weakness
deep learning you know is um
giving you access to a bunch of
parameters right and those parameters
the challenge is how do how do we
visualize those but we have access to
them so there are lots of strategies for
trying to visualize them
and so for example in this case we we
looked at you know
alzheimer's versus mild cognitive
impairment state you know stable and
progressive
uh versus controls and and you can
you know one one way you can do this is
is something uh where you sort of
visualize the layer and you project it
back into
uh brain space and you can see for
example medial temporal regions are the
most
informative when we're predicting
alzheimer's versus controls which
which makes sense um you know based on
prior work
um we find about a 93 accuracy there
but more importantly for stable versus
progressive
mci predicting you know future decline
uh we're getting above 80
accuracy um but it is important to kind
of go back and visualize
another way you can visualize is is to
use these sort of projections right so
we can
this is using something called um uh t
distributed
stochastic non-linear embedding or t-sne
you basically take a bunch of parameters
and you project them into a
two-dimensional space which preserves
the local
you know neighborhood information so
each dot here is a subject
and this is just showing that if we if
we if we go from one
to two to three uh layers which is sort
of small
for deep learning models these days um
you start to see some interesting
clusters here
uh come out for these um for these uh
groups uh this schizophrenia bipolar
disorder schizoaffective uh disorder
um and it gives you some interesting
observations and we can also then drill
down into each individual subject and
visualize
you know how they look uh relative to
the others
um but we're just getting started right
so so here here's another example let me
again hide the floating meeting controls
okay
here's another example where we're
asking the question
is our model complexity
um optimal right and and so
um using resting fmri here we're
comparing
you know components in different domains
here
and how they are linked you know or
functionally connected to
other uh component domains um and
whether
that is that that sort of accuracy when
we're trying to predict
the clinical group is improved if we use
sort of a linear relationship versus a
an additional layer versus
a third layer after that and and what
we're finding is and these are all
cross-validated what we're finding is
evidence that for example you can see
here the cognitive control
networks show evidence of of needing
additional layers additional complexity
their relationship is there but it's
it's best modeled
it needs to it needs a more complicated
model more parameters in order to model
it
uh to achieve a high the highest
accuracy
so again you can see this is really
there's a whole bunch of things we can
do here right but
but it's really getting at can we can we
use this information
the structure of the model that emerges
from this to tell us something
uh intuitive about brain regions and
brain domains
um and then i think the last example
here is is using
you know deep models to try to get at
the temporal information a little bit
more so
you can use you know something called
convolutional neural networks lets you
leverage the spatial information
uh recurrent neural networks let you
leverage you know delays
in time and so if you combine the two uh
for resting fmri data you can you can
develop a model that predicts
uh from resting fmri or from other kinds
of fmri data or temporal
uh spatial temporal data and
just as i had mentioned before we can
project down into these two-dimensional
plots here
and see where the the patients and the
controls
lie relative to one another in both the
training
and the testing data we can visualize
which components
in this case we fed in to the model we
didn't use
raw data in this case we're actually
feeding in ica components
and we have individual components that
are most discriminative
discriminative in this particular model
and we can look at the relationship to
other variables of interest for example
symptom categories
and you know some interesting things
emerge so for example if we look at
healthy
and schizophrenia we can see that the
symptom scores
kind of have this this gradient where
you have more severe and least severe
and the least severe or closer to the
controls
again the model here knew nothing about
symptoms
we're just mapping those symptoms onto
these projections
you know post hoc and and
this is the last one i promise so so
here here we're looking at
a four-way classification using again a
deep learning model um
and when we apply the projection we
found this interesting
uh result here where the schizoaffective
group
was split into two different clusters
right one that was closer
to the other groups and one was kind of
off on its own
um and you can see that the symptom
scores don't help you a whole lot
there's there's evidence that maybe
there's
there's a pretty big spread here in this
group as there are
in that group um but these kinds of
visualizations
and you know we're looking we're kind of
working currently on some different ways
to do this
but trying to visualize well what is
unique about those folks that are
misclassified or folks that are sort of
well classified um and can we look at
that in some sort of a continuous
type of measure so in summary
um you know there's a lot of information
that we've mostly been ignoring um
that we can obtain when we when we focus
on subgroups of data
or subspaces within our data um
if we focus on this sort of homogeneity
and heterogeneity aspect
it can really enhance our sensitivity to
relevant information for example
severity of illness
and as the data sets are growing more
and more open data sets are available
now this gives us an
opportunity to help us try to advance
our ability to characterize mental
illness and and replicate these these
results
um so you know just just a slide here to
mention that we
we try to release our our methods um
we've got a number of toolboxes that
release that
that implement the approaches uh that
that i have mentioned in the previous
slides
um and you know we like many others
are a big proponents of data sharing
um and also data capture in sort of
systematic ways and so we have a system
called
coins which sort of all-inclusive does
imaging and
assessments and radiology reviews um
but interesting an interesting piece of
that is um
sort of complement to that is
decentralized
analysis so with these sort of large
studies you know
if you want to do an analysis you you
have to you know have a bunch of
infrastructure and
download everything or you have to have
a cloud account or access that account
and if you want to combine it with a
data set from somewhere
somewhere else you have to get them in
the same place or find a way to do them
separately
even more so if you want to work with
groups like enigma where
about half of their data sets cannot be
centrally aggregated
you can't analyze them with more
complicated type algorithms
unless you have approaches that can you
know do
analysis in sort of a decentralized way
by passing around
metrics from data set to data set we
have a tool we built called coin stack
which is
open source uh and and does this sort of
analysis and so that's
kind of an aside if you're interested
you can check it out here
um the work in in that i presented today
is
is uh basically i just have to thank uh
the folks at the trend center
many collaborators that we work with and
our funding sources
and also thank you very much for bearing
with me i think i'm
about on time uh and without further ado
i guess
jack will take some questions now
unshare my screen
uh you can just uh just unshare your
screen so we can see
you that would be just fine um vince
firstly thank you so much for
kind of going through um you know just
really a remarkable
amount of work from from you and your
team and from
all your collaborators i mean it's
really quite uh an impressive uh
amount of firepower you guys bring to
all this
i was um as we're kind of waiting for a
few more people to
to fire off some questions i was very
interested in about you
finding out a little bit more about the
spatially constrained ica
um i suppose i've always been a little
bit concerned about ica's ability
to um for on convergence and
comparability across subjects
and whether or not the ica analytics
solutions are mathematically unique and
it sounds like spatially constrained ica
may help with that
um and maybe get a little more network
uh consistency across groups
i was just kind of curious if that was
one of the motivating factors behind the
the spatial constrained ica or if i
if i'm off base here yeah i mean that's
that that is
you know the ability to kind of run this
on individual subjects and have
comparability across
uh components i mean the the the
you know the group i see a framework uh
that we've been using for years is kind
of
a way to get at that too um
basically what you're doing is saying
i'm interested in comparing data sets
and therefore i'm imposing up front
this type of this group model right um
and this is kind of the reverse of that
which is um
you know in the sort of standard group
ica approach
you know you are running a group map and
then you're reconstructing individual
and comparable sets of components from
individual subjects right so within that
data set things are comparable and and
things work well and we can get the same
answer if we run it multiple times
you know assuming we we do these um
you know sort of we we do these repeat
analyses to kind of get guarantee that
um but if you want to cross validate
or analyze data outside of that initial
data set
you you you know up up till now have had
to
basically resort to running another ica
and then figuring out kind of how it
matches and it may not
right or just throwing away the ic model
ica model
and just going to like a regression
based uh approach
and so we were interested in sort of
leveraging the
benefits of ica and maximizing
independence and having all those
guarantees
but also allowing us to do this outside
of that original data set and so that's
kind of where
where it led us in that direction and so
we've been running
you know all sorts of analyses now with
that and the other thing that's nice is
you can do a bunch of stuff within your
study
but if you do another study and do
something completely different you can
compare
right across those studies if you use
those techniques
um so it's quite it's quite nice i i at
least
i like it a lot but you guys can try it
out we have the maps up there on our
website
and there's a paper which i think it has
neural mark in the name it talks about
it
um and so feel free to try and it's
built into the gif tools as well you can
just click on it and run it on one
subject if you want
what were the um you know what you've
had the benefit of having some pretty
remarkable sample sizes to be able to uh
put through some of your methods um
especially with some of the
i'm sure this is important not only for
ica but also some of the by clustering
stuff you talked about there are
several of those big data sets like the
human connect dome project or
abcd for development um you mentioned
the uk biobank i think
um somewhere in there what sort of
sample sizes
do we kind of need to have i mean i'm
thinking the uk biobank is just a
ridiculous amount of data but obviously
that's kind of a rare resource
but what sort of sample sizes do you
guys look for when you're trying to run
ica
kind of analyses i mean with
you in terms of what you need well i
think it really depends on what you
what questions you're asking okay um and
uh i i don't think there's a minimum per
se
i would say if you're interested in
individual
prediction you know sort of accuracy
scores in a binary classification case
then
you know more is better right because
you um
you know you can um there's a you know
there's a certain variance
that you have to account for around your
accuracy and
and you're kind of bounded by that if
you say you have
you know 100 subjects and your variance
is five percent
right plus or minus five percent or plus
or minus ten percent well that can be a
pretty big difference right if you're
talking
about clinical guiding clinical
decisions right
and so the the more you can ramp up that
data that the more you can reduce that
and be more confident in in the answer
but so i guess i would say there
but that doesn't mean that you're not
learning some useful information from
from the smaller data set um so i guess
i
i think it really does depend on what
you're predicting and how large that
effect is
in the data it's why we've kind of tried
to look at group effects and
are they rough do they replicate you
know things like that so
i was going to say that one of the but
i'm not yeah
but i'm not you know and again like if
you're predicting
behavior and behavior is highly variable
uh then that's gonna that's gonna be
your rate limiting step
right your rate limiting you know part
of that study
is the fact that you know you your your
correlations like
you know on average 0.2 right or 0.3
yeah that's going to be hard to predict
right with with
you know any any level of accuracy
so on your spatiotemporal dynamics
application uh i was particularly
interested in that and i was just kind
of curious if you've noticed
uh how the variability spatially
is structured like for example is it
cyto or tectonically constrained um
every are you notice any things that
like that um and also does the time
scale
play an important role of the data
acquisition
yeah so you know we i would like
i'm pretty sure there will be some
interesting
arc tectonic links there but we haven't
tackled that per se
just you know i would i would do it if
we had a 7t scanner and try to get it
you know so
i think the layer specific stuff can
help a little bit with that
it doesn't get you cyto arc tectonics
but it gets you a little bit of input
output right and things like that
right um you know so we've been looking
more at sort of the macro scale
right because we're kind of working with
more standard 3t data sets
uh at this point i think the time scale
does matter um
and you you see things that are kind of
as i showed in that stateline analysis
you know the
the drop-off of the you know hanging
together of the state is is much
faster right in in the patients than it
is in the then it is in the controls
um and you know there's a lot of
interesting
um elements that you can glean from from
delay
uh as well i i think you know ultimately
we also have to remember that
we're looking at again very macroscopic
level
data and we you know there i didn't
really get into
sort of multimodal but we can you can do
multimodal you know analysis and collect
multiple types of data from
from the same person and then if you
have a number of subjects with those
same data types you can start to try to
link those scales together
um and that can give you more
information as well and i think there's
a lot you can do there
that's great are you aware of any
efforts to apply models like the ones
you've described
to patients that do or do not respond to
therapies
um i'm sure that i'm sure
yes i i've certainly come across some of
those
um so the idea would be
like selecting individuals who would be
most responsive right so that would be
the potential
one potential scenario where you could
use it we've talked a lot about
um just in the context of not
necessarily therapy but
treatment uh in general you know are
you know can you pre-select individuals
who are more likely to be responsive
right to a given treatment right um
uh and so but yeah i mean i think that
would be we i haven't done that myself
um looking at sort of uh response to
therapy i
i think there's some data where
at the mind research network um eric
klaus and katie
are looking at sort of uh cognitive
behavioral therapy
and mindfulness and some other measures
like that um
and so that will be eventually something
where we can try
you know try that on um but yeah
i think i mean i think that's a great
area um to apply this to
that's great now one of the things which
is always seems to be a you
mentioned rate limiting factors is that
individuals don't often have
necessarily access to high performance
compute
clusters at their institutions for
whatever reason or
they maybe they're you know not really
fully bought into
you know giving money to amazon i was
curious if you might tell us a little
bit more about coinstack
sure yeah so so what we're doing there
is um
and we call it decentralized learning i
think google calls it federated learning
um essentially what we're doing is
um you download this application
and you map your data to it so you maybe
map
your structural mri data to it and then
you
you see consortia and you can join a
consortia right so suppose you and five
of your friends download coinstack and
somebody
creates a consortia you know and and
you you join that right uh and then the
consortia creator
sets up an analytic model or a
computation and that might be
do a vbm analysis of these data or it
could be a free surfer analysis or it
could be
we have group ica in there as well this
this sort of spatially constrained group
ica
um and then
you know uh and then what happens is
that the in the
you know they specify which variables
are needed for the analysis
and then the individual um sites
uh see those variables and they map
their
you know do the mapping of their
variables to those right so the names
uh match they don't have to match but
you you match the very the data
right uh and uh and then you click go
and then it runs the analysis
locally so basically it takes that
analysis and it runs
uh locally without moving the data
it produces some derivatives potentially
adds noise to that
and then aggregates it privately and can
iterate
you know so you can you know you may
need just one iteration you may need
many depending on what
what you're doing if it's just a
regression one will be enough
um if it's like a support vector machine
you need more
um and and then you get a global you
know
answer uh to that uh solution and so
that
that you know again has multiple
benefits
you know and it's complementary if you
can put all your data in one place and
have everything and have access to all
of it and run it
uh there that would be great but you
know sometimes you don't have the
resources
sometimes the data can't be shared right
since
you're collaborating with somebody and
they're not allowed to we we have a data
set
um this this uh f burn data set that
that i've been
showing a lot here um we've been arguing
with the irb for
you know for over a decade trying to get
them to allow us to share it and they
will not
let us share it because it didn't have
you know data sharing language in there
when it was collected which was way
before
you know this became common yeah um
and so you know there may be cases where
you have rare disorders or you have
identifiable information other kinds of
data that you're looking at that might
be sensitive and so
i think it's a useful complement
and you can imagine connecting that to
large
pool data as well so pool what you can
and bring in what you can right right
are there any hardware requirements that
uh if someone wanted to become a coin
stack
uh a node in your system would they have
any um it's
it's at the moment it's just run on
individual
analyses and so it really depends on
what you want to run okay so
so you know and at the rate limiting
step is how much local data you're
analyzing
so if you're if you're analyzing a lot
of data locally you need to have enough
storage for that data and enough
computation to run it so it's whatever
your local scale happens to be right
yeah right exactly but you don't need to
scale it
to the entire amount of data that you're
analyzing across all the sites
um and the other thing where
we've got um we're sort of working on
this now we've got it sort of a sort of
a pre-alpha version of it
is is like a sort of a headless coin
stack i guess i'll call it which is
if i have a um you know a data set and i
just want to make it open
right for point stack people so you
can't get the data
but you can always see the coin stack
node
and you can control the mapping right
and run the analysis then that that and
that would be a
great for some of these larger data sets
where you want to provide a resource
right for the for the community or a
benchmark for people or
you know etc and so that i think is
is something that could be hosted um
and potentially should should require
maybe a data center if you're going to
have a lot of people using it
right right are there any um is it all
or nothing either you're
you're you know only say sharing like
statistical results or the raw data or
not at all or are there kind of levels
of of granularity
of what you can be shared um
so yeah it depends again on the
computation you do so so there's a
there's a couple levels like you can you
can make consortia private
if you want so so only your friends can
join
um you can you can pick an algorithm
that
sort of passes derivatives like maybe it
passes
gradient weights or maybe it passes you
know beta values or something like that
right
you can also do something called
differential privacy which
it takes the derivative and maybe you
feel like i don't even want people that
i'm worried that people might machine
learn on my data right and figure out
even though it's
it's it's you know not that informative
they might still be able to
put those pieces together right and so
uh
with differential privacy allows you to
add some some
some noise structured noise to it that
then gets sort of averaged out when you
do the
uh the aggregation and and we even have
another one that
that's using encryption now which is
basically sort of bank level encryption
um where we you encrypt the derivatives
before you share them and then you learn
on the encrypted derivatives so there's
different there's different levels there
that we're
working towards for sure because
different people will have different
needs
so what is next in the world of
big data brain science in this space
i think i don't know there's so much
to do here i mean i i feel like um
i think we're learning a lot but i also
i guess what i
the things that i worry about i guess
i'll say are
there's too much turning of the crank
without
thinking about what's underneath the
crank right and and so
um for example i
i like the i mean i love all this i love
the fact that there's a lot of data
available
but i'm also wary that you know there's
a lot of reuse
and studies are going to start to be
correlated to one another
right yeah and another thing is that
if everybody uses the same pipeline
right to process their data
you've baked in biases right
so think about by you know biological
diversity right
analytical diversity is probably good
too it's not necessarily a bad thing
um and it can give you some benefits it
can give you um
you know some information right um
i do think that um that they're
you know things are accelerating and i
feel hopeful
about um having brain imaging lead
towards
some some more useful clinical
um tools um you know before too long
because i feel like we're
sort of getting getting a better handle
on you know replicability
and um generalizability and and things
like that you know still
still working on that but these large
studies are helping
that's great well and then yeah i'm
still like we're doing a lot with deep
learning
yeah um and i think again developing
models that are interpretable so one of
the one of the ways that we're doing
that is we're taking
ica which one of the things i like about
it is i find it
somewhat interpretable to get out you
know multiple networks that interact
you know with one another and so you can
build that
inside of a deep learning model right
and then start to look at
um instead of just this sort of massive
set of of you know hundreds of thousands
of weights you now have them segregated
by
networks you can look at subspaces that
was kind of what i was getting at with
the complexity analysis i showed
um so anyway there's just a few things
someone else will give you a completely
different answer probably
that's undoubtedly the case well uh
vince calhoun thank you so much for for
joining us and sharing your work with us
uh what an
amazing amount of work and what an
amazing team you have and i hope
everything is going well for you
after the big move to georgia um but uh
anyway thank you everybody who joined us
and uh we look forward to seeing you
next week
thanks again vince appreciate it my
pleasure pleasure to be here